l'économie de la portée
[Musique]
est loupé un truc je trouve beaucoup
moins qu'un pas que thomas sotto il
[Musique]
vous trompez vous trompez sur la route
époque qu'est ce que j'ai dit mal
mal j'étais plutôt d'accord avec vous en
plus cette campagne est pourri pour une
fois pas parlé politique parce qu'on
savait il était d'une lâcheté crasse et
j'en fais partie parce qu'alain d'action
politique mais on savait pas que les
journalistes les détend lâche et qui
sont capables oui de la
chose est question vous ne répondez pas
moi qui suis lâche oui pour tout seul
dans son nom est ce qu'on peut se finir
un peu chacun des bonnes énergies comme
ça un petit peu c'était le principe dans
certaines traditions fausse identité
pour une méditation vandales allons-y la
musique
utilisée un petit peu son alimentation
et hors énergie le groupe aimer ça fait
du bien mais oui ça fait du bien on
devrait tous les femmes et chez nous est
plusieurs dans la rue surtout
là jean-claude justement on va continuer
d'en discuter mon cher jean
claude c'est pas que votre prénom c'est
quoi c'est thomas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l heure
poisson d'avril
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quoi
ce aux mines oui mais ça veut rien dire
mais j'ai toujours entendu soleil abba
va falloir consulter
alors j'ai toujours chanté comme une
crèche est où le soleil se lève
alors cessé complètement avoir la balle
au sens physique il faut expliquer
pourquoi pour ceux qui nous rejoindre et
maintenant quoi thomas sotto de
télématin est avec nous et la soufflante
à l'heure j'ai appelé thomas porcher est
un thomas sotto et il se trouve qu'on se
connaît avec thomas parce qu'on a
travaillé
cet accent du tarn thomas là il vient
d'où
les matinées par les inconnus le fait
pas
faux
or de m'aider
[Musique]
qu est-ce qu isabelle vitari
on de mise
c'est ça je vais pas inventer c'était en
gros je crois que c'était même sur votre
femme est une étuve ailleurs une unité
n'est via les touches tribus et au
désordre
problème vraiment vous n'hésitez pas
vous pouvez tout à fait sortir dans
steam et que vous n'avez pas votre péché
surtout pas que quelqu'un avait dit il
ya des colères qui sont saines une
candidate à la présidentielle comme ça
on dit martin luther king se sont mis en
colère c'était ségolène royal
[Rires]
détends toi trouve un toit est serré
comme ça ça te coince la gorge et en
parts lâche tout tu vois
tu as raison c'était le soleil est pas
le sommeil est le meilleur moment de ma
vie c'est quand tu sais quand tu as dit
ah oui c'est vrai que c'est joli aussi
le sommeil s'est passé ça c'est moi je
suis au top du bonheur là quand j
ça va réviser b et on a des nouvelles de
mes paroles dès maintenant alors non ça
c'est vraiment la côte est
et est père dont elle avait extrait de
te faire n'importe quoi je lui ai dit tu
ne me parles pas sur ce ton droit de
parler